well brian shows on the las vegas strip
are dark
and the performers and the entertainers
are certainly suffering
tonight many of them gathered on the las
vegas strip to send a
unique message to lawmakers eight news
now reporter joe moeller was there and
he joins us now live with more on their
message
joe las vegas is known as the
entertainment capital when the
entertainment industry provides
thousands of jobs here in the valley
well this evening hundreds of
demonstrators came out here to the strip
to shed light on how badly the industry
is being impacted
[Music]
from the live music to shows on water
las vegas is
entertainment entertainment is the
lifeblood of this town millions come
here to be
entertained as the pandemic continues
thousands in the entertainment industry
remain without work
we have no idea when we're ever going to
go back to work
a summer heat wave did not stop hundreds
from the industry from taking to the
strip
for a rally wednesday we've been out of
work for well over
six months from wardrobe attendance to
stagehands people from all parts of the
industry
say they want more done by lawmakers to
come up with a plan to get the industry
back up and running
if governor sysolak states that we can
open our theaters we don't just reopen
the next day
it's not that simple we need audience
members we need people to fly to las
vegas we need people for hotel rooms
we need any number of things to get our
business back in place
we need the aid organizer david shulman
says he wants people to know how bad the
pandemic is
impacting them and for people to know
how big the industry is for the area
we can say that there are 68 thousand
entertainment workers out of work here
in the city of las vegas
that's approximately 2.8 million but
until people see our numbers
they don't really understand what that
means demonstrators say not only are
they without work
but many are still without unemployment
benefits it makes me sad it's upsetting
it's hurting i've tried to help as many
friends and even family members as i can
try to get through to unemployment
organizers say yet another demonstration
is planned for september first and on
that evening of that demonstration
buildings across the valley will
turn their lights red to stand in
solidarity with the entertainment
industry and the workers in it
reporting live here on the las vegas
strip i'm john muller 8 news now